meinst du das wird nie was er etwas
glaube dass willkommen bei einem neuen
video erinnert euch jetzt wahrscheinlich
es ist doch sonntag 18 uhr und der leben
video hab ich ja letzte woche auch schon
gemacht aber ich hab mir so das letzte
woche also diese ab sonntag ist wirklich
heftig googelt deswegen kommt es immer
sonntags statt montag ein video und ja
ich war mir diesmal gar nicht so sicher
arbeit werden das wort für ein video
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht komm gehst
du einfach mal auf chatroulette das
machen ja auch ziemlich viele andere
youtuber und versuchst du so ein
bisschen also ich hab mir jetzt so für
mich überlegt okay ich jetzt gleich hier
hin und versuche handynummern zu klären
also von frauen am besten
ich weiß nicht ob ich es schaffe einfach
mal testen wer gar nicht lange da war
wir kommen direkt mal zur sache wenn es
euch gefällt oder wenn jetzt ein
vernünftiges wiederum kommen kann gerne
nach oben gehen und dann gibts auch
einige noch eine zweite folge und los
geht's das geht alles klar muss ich mich
anders positionieren damit ich besser
aus dem was in meinem schokoladenseite
so summe zwischen lesen hallo hallo ich
bin ja richtig was geht ja wenigstens
noch kanal war ich schreib dir dass ich
habe 122 abonnenten schon haben wir die
sehr okay dann nicht selber schulde ich
meine guck mich mal so immer noch nicht
hey was geht watte everything ok kannst
du deutsch do you speak german can have
your number navarro fax adwords me i'm
very verletzten ist im juni tochter ja
eigentlich bin ich noch ganz gesund zu
alles klar
sorry scheiße hallo hallo
warum drücken dialekt was mache ich
falsch was marie curie weight bei mir
nicht ich versuche die ganze zeit so
telefonnummer zu klären
aber jedes also ich weiß nicht wie die
meisten nämlich aus deutschland machen
direktem weg woran liegt das
sammelt sich so scheiße bei mir immer
wie hat bist du weg was ihr da macht
auch an das ist so ein knopf weist der
ist bei dir auf der tastatur krieg deine
kriege ich deine handynummer hat es
schon mal bei jemandem gezogen
nein nein ich mich etwas die dingsbums
johanning von den aussenseitern mütze
guckst du gerne youtube ja bist du löwen
kind ja und sonst so alles gut
hey was ja es lustig heißt du alex mir
ich habe hier auch verleiten die damals
wo ich noch mit einem freund unterwegs
in jackson hole mir ich hab ich hab nur
gesagt bilder von mir irgendwie
ich kann die deutschen ja die kommt
deutschlands aus
ja dann klärte doch klar festhalten hin
kenne youtube
denn wenn ich jetzt mal fragen was
schätzt ihr wie viele abonnenten habe
ich auf youtube wo kaiser im rat den ich
gut aber nicht so
ich weiß ich auch okay also ich denke so
ist haben die 4000 oder so 4000 und do 9
100 von 900 bis 1000 was ist wenn ich
jetzt sagen würde ich auch über 100000
würdet ihr mir das glauben er ist ja
ohne witz ich mache sogar drachen video
seo da bist du glücklich der der bank
kennst du mich ich habe meinen videos
gesehen was dagegen wenn ich das alter
du kannst du kannst dein instagram nahm
sein jetzt und dann folgen bestimmt
welche man warte warte was auch heute
morgen wenn das video eines folgt ihm
dann merkt der aber der hat auch sehr
viele okay ja gut wenn das christen uns
beiden nicht passt dann gebe ich mir
weiter auf die suche aber lange trotzdem
meinte das wird nie was
also eigentlich hätte ich mir da schon
mehr erwartet sowie der 1
er war schuldig drauf eine der romand ja
der kletter mit jede bei mir zwar nicht
so gezogen ich hoffe es hat euch denn
noch gefallen weiß ja ich denke mal so
8019 drin oder instagram selbst etwas
eingebildet hier oben links geht's
weiter mit meinem letzten video das war
hier alex privatnummer 6 ab wir sind uns
nichts mittwoch wieder schön dass sie
zugeguckt und verein